Quadra is universally cruel because it's
made by force-feeding ducks or sometimes
geese massive quantities of food to
enlarge delivers physiologically Ducks
are waterfowl and they're fundamentally
different than human beings our
this is foie gras fattened duck or goose
liver a modern day delicacy was a
culinary history stretching all the way
back to ancient Egypt many people don't
know what it is but there's a small
group of activists determined to ban it
the city of Chicago imposed a ban that
was repealed a short two years after it
took effect the state of California
passed a ban that goes into effect in
July of 2012 mark Pastore owns Encanto
restaurant in San Francisco and he wants
to continue being allowed to serve foie
gras foie gras is a special food it's
not a food that one would eat every day
it's something that is often it might be
used to celebrate occasions when we
start taking away foods that can play
that kind of role in culture I think we
start to diminish our culture I think we
losing our freedom roland passu owns la
folie restaurant in san francisco and is
also against the ban this is the lawn
where you can really blossoms and do a
lot of things than arrogant we don't let
you do and I applaud America for that
but when I see that I'm saying are we
going backwards we're not talking about
a product that that anybody thinks
should be consumed really except for a
small handful of chefs and promoters
it's not something that anybody is
particularly committed to it's it's not
something that's that's really important
and it's it's something that's extremely
cruel bryan pease founder of the Animal
Protection Rescue League says that
banning foie gras is a pressing animal
rights issue you're actually seeking to
induce a disease in the animal
essentially you're creating a liver
that's that's ten over ten times it's
normal size wah grah is not the result
of cruel practice Bailon Lynne akin is
an attorney and founder of the keep food
legal foundation a group that helped
overturn the Chicago foie gras ban he
says that the force feeding process is
not as brutal as opponents make it out
to be it's a bird that can digest or can
swallow a fish whole a large fish it
swallow that without having any sort of
repercussions it's a process that lasts
a couple weeks you feed the bird and at
some point they rather than being afraid
of the the person who's giving them the
food
they actually come over to eat the food
producers here in the United States
and there are only three are very very
very small and they work under what I
would characterize as an artisan method
of production I don't know what are what
artisan is supposed to mean but you know
I having been in this farm if that's
what artists it means I don't want
anything artisan on my plate the process
of gavage which is feeding the ducks
through a funnel is handled in a very
careful way with the foie gras producers
here in the United States and many of
the images that the anti foie gras folks
use a really images that are lifted from
more industrial foie gras producers that
you might find in other countries around
the world this is some of the inside
footage that piece took of various farms
around the world and has posted on his
website the way we got the footage was
just by going to the farm we go at
nighttime so and we could just if we
didn't you know break in or anything
like that we just walked in and the
Ducks are being force-fed three times
per day so but when you say you didn't
break in you mean what do you mean you
but you were invited or no we weren't
invited either so we we walked in so
when I say we didn't break in I mean we
didn't break any lot in other words the
door was unlocked we didn't have to
climb any fences or anything trespassing
to get footage of supposed animal
cruelty is one thing but chefs and
farmers have also accused anti foie gras
activists of stealing ducks and
vandalizing their property in 2003 one
chef even received a threatening
videotape of his family and multiple
notes reading stop or be stopped certain
chefs and farmers have told me that
they've been threatened and vandalized
by anti foie gras folks like 10 years
ago that happened they're still talking
about it did you or your organization
have anything to do yeah no that was
something that was an isolated case of
something that happened that's one of
the things that chefs that want to dig
in their heels and keep serving it will
say they'll use that as some kind of
justification that some you know Laurent
Manrique was vandalized back in 2003 so
all right would you know what do you
want me to do about that chefs and
farmers tend to bring up the string of
threats vandalism and lawsuits that
occurred in 2003 because these
intimidation tactics led directly to a
settlement between
pz's group in California's only
foie-gras farmer paving the way for the
anti foie gras legislation but it was
because of these threats that pastori
decided to begin serving foie gras in
the first place I think the only way
that you ultimately stop bullying
tactics is to stand up to them some
other Restaurant tours some notable ones
like Wolfgang Puck that essentially
waved the white flag immediately I don't
think that they actually helped promote
good discourse on this issue while peas
in his organization of won the
California foie gras fight for now Lynn
akin is optimistic that the failed
Chicago band offers some hope for the
future of food freedom the chicago van i
guess if there's any one big lesson it's
that ultimately choice trumps it should
and it does and individual rights are
the most important thing that we have as
Americans so we could shoot a nugget or
food or milk or butter we should not eat
foie gras what is next the fish the
chicken the beef the pork
where are we going to stop
[Music]